jamar chase
there is definite steam you know it was
penney sewell the oregon tackle penciled
in to cincinnati at number five for a
while that pendulum has swung hard the
other way jamar chase there's now a
feeling is the guy the lsu reunion
between joe burrow and jamar chase and
there it is another mock draft with
jamar chase
going to the cincinnati bengals at
number five and sewell dropping down to
number seven biting kneecaps for dan
campbell in detroit right well i could
see that i mean you know again that's
dan campbell anthony lynn they'd believe
like in physicality running the ball
right campbell came from the saints with
that big hulking offensive line has the
parcels background so that's why i went
with that with detroit but yeah that
number five pick is interesting it
definitely is i was disappointed
yesterday to see peter king had jamar
chase there too i thought i was gonna be
kind of like you know rare that way but
uh
i've heard that in the bengals
organization this is a real discussion
between these two right here and i was i
won't lie i was a guy that was a week
ago 10 days ago going take penne sewell
protect joe burrow you know you're in
the afc north with all those pass
rushers everything like that that's the
right thing to do but when i had to
finally sit down and do my mock draft
and play gm of the bengals
i just came away going
all right yeah you could go penne sewell
and get the receiver and get uh the
receiver at the top of the second
or
you could get a superstar receiver
and still get a good o-lineman at the
top of the second and that's where i
decided to go like wait a superstar old
lineman doesn't change an offense around
but a superstar wide receiver does
and you can build a good unit as far as
an offensive alliance together without
one being a superstar and i think that's
what swayed me and i just went you know
what go ahead do it it makes sense he's
too special he's too explosive you know
he stayed in shape with what you saw on
the pro day i mean really jamar chase
was the best receiver in last year's
draft like we talked about yesterday he
would have been the best receiver in
last year's draft he would have been
drafted before rugs everybody liked that
he's got superstar written all over him
i think that's why you can't pass him if
you're the bengals and you throw on top
of it the idea that joe burrow knows him
so that's right played with him so well
right
and
i you know last week when we played the
comments from joe burrow and he was
very uh
non-committed diplomatic about right
about chase versus sewell at five you
could interpret that to mean he wasn't
stumping for chase maybe he doesn't want
chase the reality is he's probably said
everything he needs to say that's right
behind the scenes and they still have to
worry a little bit
a little bit
that maybe the falcons
decide to go jamar chase at number four
you can't let that fire get too far out
of control in cincinnati for chase
because that could make the falcons say
well you know what we're getting rid of
julio jones anyway we're ready to give
him away let's make jamar chase not kyle
pitts the next weapon in our office yeah
that i mean that that'll be interesting
that would be interesting and you know
it does make you think a little bit with
atlanta and the julio you know on the on
the trade
talks and all everything like that but
uh i think it makes sense you know for
the bengals to make this type of move
chase you know the thing about chase is
really you know physically there's just
nothing he can't do he can beat you deep
he plays bigger than his size 50 50
balls for a guy his size it's
unbelievable how he comes down with it
almost every time and then i think
what's really special about him too is
he can improve as a route runner but it
it doesn't even matter because he gets
open because he's so explosive and quick
in short areas and then with the ball in
his hands mike that's where he's just a
little different than the rest of the
group because he can break tackles he
can break your ankles he can make you
look silly and do all that type of stuff
or just beat you with pure speed i mean
it was a special connection with him and
joe burrows good as we've ever seen with
any in college football and i think
that's why you just can't pass it up if
you're the bengals
and if they do it i respect their
willingness to forget about the mistake
that was made with john ross four years
ago not be scarred by that two different
guys two different skill sets right two
different drafts two different ceilings
two different floors
and uh and also quarterback who knows
the guy extremely well and uh so i'm
coming around on that as well even
though it's safer to go with sewell yeah
you you you become a team that
is a high-end contender in one of the
toughest divisions in football if jamar
chase has a randy moss type of an impact
on the nfl next year first you got to
get boro healthy too to make that happen
all right you have a trade a quarterback
needy team that traded for sam darnold
trading down to get more picks from the
washington football team which springs
up 11 spots from 19
to get north dakota state's trey lance
that would be something and that would
probably
get quarterback ryan fitzpatrick the
current washington football team starter
to say more than a few f words not
football team or fitzpatrick right
you're right now you know trey lance
being pro ready it would be less
threatening for a guy like fix patrick
than it would be for like two of last
year and things like that i i would say
that but yeah it would be that same sort
of situation listen i'm one
that i am not a believer that carolina
will take one of these quarterbacks
sitting there at number eight i mean i
there again i i look at it and go wait
they they coach mack jones in the senior
bowl right there was rumors that they
were looking to trade up in the draft a
little bit anyways and then the 49ers
trade and the rumors are it's mac jones
and i don't think it's any coincidence
that a few days later you see them make
a move for sam darnold i think their
guys they feel like is gone so
i think they're going to look to trade
out of that spot and you know washington
of course has a need there and i know
there's some teams that are hot on trey
lance and think he can be maybe the next
josh allen and that type of stuff and
washington a team with the need at the
sit at the position you know the proper
formula as far as what's there right now
and i just look at like um
uh you know
ron rivera
and
turner scott turner the offensive
coordinator and think they have some
history with a trey lance type of
quarterback in cam newton and that could
work with the way their team set up so
that's why i ultimately you know kind of
pulled the trigger there with that type
of trade
i always root for chaos you mentioned
mac jones and how the panthers
were maybe trying to finagle a trade to
get him maybe that's what put pressure
on the 49ers to pull the trigger when
they did i the chaos would be the 49ers
taking someone other than jones
and then what are the panthers yeah
right right if their guy ended up like
if mac jones was their guy and now he's
ended up there on them you're right that
would be uh that would be pretty
interesting i envision that though
still
if mac jones falls in my heart of hearts
where okay
let's say the 49ers take trey lance i
still don't think carolina will do it
and i think then when we get to eight
and nine that's when you i i would say
that's when we see new england maybe
make a play for a mac jones and get up
there and get them that that would be if
that did happen would be my scenario
like mock draft 2.0 for that scenario
there
or or seven with the lions you can have
matt patricia
call his old boss
and try to work on a trade to get the
patriots in position to to jump in front
of the panthers just in case yeah
because i i hey we talked about it last
hour yeah owners got a big say in
carolina owners got a big say mac jones
is there at eight
david tepper like the same why are you
even asking me of course we're taking
mack jones we'll worry about sam darnold
later this is part of our plan we didn't
pick up the option on darnold for a
reason the reason was maybe mac jones
was gonna slip through the cracks and we
were gonna get him so that part of it
potentially fascinating all right um
let's let's take another look at uh at
what you have in your mock draft how
about number 11 you do have a patriots
trade
up a few spots now
peter king had
the patriots sitting put and taking
devonta smith you've got the patriots
jumping up to get his teammate jaylen
waddle i do i mean again the patriots
hey there's not like
i think one position i look at on their
team
right there to just go oh man you know
they need this one guy
i don't think they're going to be in the
market for any pass rushers might be
that might be available there at that
air you know area from what they did
with matt you don they still got chase
vinovich on the edge on the other side
and they're not big into like pass
rushers anyways in the first round a
whole lot so yeah i look at jaylen
waddle it's just too too special of a
football player and for the offense they
want to run for whoever's the
quarterback going into the future i just
think jalen wattle is like yeah he can
fill that julian edelman void of all
those underneath option rats jerk rats
and all those type of things let alone
he's a weapon on top of that so you got
a guy that's a great route runner he's
more slot oriented but man he's got big
time big play ability uh yeah it's it's
it's one i i don't know i just took a
shot in the dark i i could see the
patriots being in the market for one of
these alabama wide receivers
i got two points to make before we slide
past this one there's some noise out
there that the giants are actually
looking receivers so maybe they would
take waddle under that scenario which i
i when i heard it i said oh where did
they get a guy can you go there they
gotta why would they want to
just there's some noise out there that
maybe receiver is where they're looking
at number 11 so we shall see another one
too if we can show the 9 through 16 card
something i was told very reliably and
you know as you get closer and closer to
the draft you have the people you trust
the people you don't trust the people
who kind of fall in the middle this
comes from someone that i trust who has
proven over time to have an incredible
understanding of how the board is going
to fall can we look at sims 9 through 16
please when we can pull that up
i'm told that if when the cardinals
are on the board right at 16 right
if jalen waddle is gone as he is under
that estimation if patrick certain is
gone as he is right under your mock
draft if jc horn is gone as he is under
your mock draft the pick at 16 for the
cardinals will be tulsa linebacker zavin
collins write it down in ink
that that's interesting i mean listen
they they could use somebody in the
middle of their in the middle of their
defense in general that's why i got
christian barrymore because i came away
with them just going you know
you know one
they got isaiah simmons he's this ball
hawking going to be around the middle of
the field middle linebacker you know
added that with like you know jordan
hicks who's there on the roster but run
defense was their issue in arizona last
year they got to get better at that type
of stuff i'm a big fan of dave and
collins that'd be interesting that
really would be i didn't really think
about that match there but collins is i
mean as big as he is athletic as he is
he could do anything as far as that's
concerned and he's got a lot of
versatility for that vance joe steve
vance joseph defense so that's that
makes sense i get that
six four 250 pound linebacker he said
not that long ago guys built like me
play edge rusher i mean there's no
comparable brian urlacher is the only
real comparable and that's a high
ceiling for this guy but he played
quarterback in high school just like
erlacker did he's versatile he's a
playmaker and he's kind of flown under
the radar
16 is his ceiling if those other guys
are gone certain horn waddle if they're
gone
watch uh zaven collins become the next
member of the arizona cardinals all
right justin fields where is he gonna go
where is he gonna land let's see the
next page of the chris sims mock draft
he's got four quarterbacks gone in the
top ten there's 17 through 24. i think
chris forgot about justin field chris
explain yourself well i you know i got
here to this area right and let's just
leave it here for a minute you know with
this page on
you know okay so yeah i got them falling
as you could see with justin fields i
got through you know the tens for the
most part there and i
i couldn't quite find a match i know the
patriots some people think that i don't
think justin fields is the patriots type
of guy the patriots have a keen eye for
throwers and i gotta think justin fields
issues jump out to them
then you go to the other teams all right
washington we know they made the trade
the bears at 20 mike
i mean do you think the bears do you
think that this is where i didn't know
but do you think the bears have the
green light to draft the quarterback
right now i would think they don't
at pick 20. why so they can put
themselves in the same situation that
they just did with mitchell trubisky
where some like the next group of guys
comes in and has to deal with a
quarterback that they didn't pick
because the prior regime did that so
that's where i had a hard time thinking
that and then i got to pittsburgh at 24
mike and i decided to go the all in on
one more year with big ben type of thing
and they get the center from from
alabama so that's where yeah on this
page here no justin fields what do you
think tell me your thoughts
i think the key in chicago is ted
phillips the president of the team if he
is finally
on the hot seat if he is finally going
to be accountable for revolving door of
gms and coaches that haven't gotten them
to where they need to be for the past 22
years then maybe he's got some sway to
buy some time for everyone and say let's
go ahead and take a quarterback and
let's give these guys i've been to the
playoffs to the last three years let's
give these guys a chance to groom a
quarterback let's give matt maggie the
chance let's give ryan pace the chance
even though he's the one that took
trubisky trading up to get him so that
that to me is the wild card in chicago
but i agree with you that that's a
conversation you know you had washington
trade up to eight to get trey lance
that's not something the bears are going
to get the clearance to do because they
don't know who's going to be there right
and you're essentially agreeing to keep
the coach in the gm around for multiple
more years if you do something like that
so i look i i just think that once you
get to that third page 17 to 24
that's when you start seeing somebody
spring up to get fields if he's still
there yeah that would be my thought
right right and then you know that gets
into
you know who would that be at the end of
the first round is the is it an atlanta
is it the detroit lions something like
that spring you know springing up from
the end of the start of the second round
to jump up there and do that you know
that's where it gets really interesting
and as you can see here you know really
there's no quarterback needs with any of
the teams 25 through 32
except for the team that's perfectly
built right now and has no needs at all
and maybe can look to the future
and you know i always said justin fields
to the pittsburgh steelers would be a
great thing for him because he could sit
behind big ben and all that well i found
one that's better justin fields to tampa
bay and work on mechanics with brady a
guy that actually knows that type of
stuff and do all that that's ultimately
where i ended up going i just don't
think they would pass him up if he was
sitting there
now would would there be the same
reaction as there was in green bay last
year if the buccaneers use a first round
pick on a quarterback probably not
probably not right because like because
yeah brady's got two more years right
right he said so yes he's got two more
years right and if for some reason he
sticks around longer than that oh well
justin
can you
go ahead and continue to sit on the
bench just like jimmy g did it's not
going to be like it was in 2014. in 2014
it pissed him off when the patriots used
a second round pick on jimmy garoppolo i
think he'd understand yes if fields
makes it all the way to 32 and they say
hey we you know we got to run a team
after you retire tom and if you do only
have two more years come on what do you
expect us to do yeah i think he could
get his head around that completely
you're right it's a totally different
scenario from what he was involved with
jimmy g it's a totally different
scenario from rogers and jordan love i
mean again the writing's on the wall
brady's still really good but we know
he's not a top five quarterback in the
league or anything like that that's
where it's different from the rogers
green bay situation we knew he was a top
five quarterback and you're going wait
what you're taking a quarterback and
he's got a lot of years left like
there's been no talk about the end in
sight yet and we're still drafting a
quarterback huh that's where that one's
weird so yeah you know again but i mean
i'm with you too mike
i mean i guess the the reality of the
situation is if he gets to like 23 24
to that area and nobody's drafted him
then i do think it becomes a little bit
of that conversation of okay what what
team maybe in the top 10 does look to
trade up and get into the end of the
first round and and and steal justin
fields away that's going to be
interesting but i i envision him falling
i really do and we'll see if i'm right
and if you're the buccaneers and you
could get someone's 2022 first round
pick to move out of that 32nd spot and
go down i don't know how many spots go
down 10 12 spots that 2022 first round
pick is valuable because it's normal
scouting rules that's right hopefully
next year um how do we get here though
where you know justin fields has that
great game against clemson gets blown up
sir in the first half
is just throwing dimes in the second
half and and blows trevor lawrence's
team off the field
how does how does he slide all the way
to 32. that's just astounding to me well
you know again i don't think we would
have sat here and thought lamar jackson
would have slid to 32 either and i would
sit here and tell you lamar jackson was
a better prospect than justin fields i
had no questions about that at all you
know so i think really
again there's a lot of talent there with
justin fields i think everybody likes
the guy the human being
but i go back to the the base thing i
said
some of the issues throwing
i would think are there they're scaring
teams there's no doubt there's very few
people in the nfl who really know
anything about throwing the football and
who can really teach a quarterback the
right things to do or how to fix certain
things and i know that's hard for people
to believe but i am telling you there is
very few people in the nfl that have any
clue about that stuff that's why you see
a lot of these quarterbacks they go work
with other people that's because their
coach doesn't really tell them that type
of stuff some basics and all of that and
with justin's fields issues
they're they're they're big for somebody
like me who's into the quarterback
technique and all that type of stuff and
i
even for me a guy that i know i can
teach and have been doing this for a
long time with my dad and my brother and
all that i would worry if i could fix
justin fields let alone if i'm not a guy
who doesn't know anything about it can
you correct all those issues i think
that's what's going to scare people or
is scaring people about justin fields
what's the main thing that needs to be
fixed the biggest thing is like
it's it's really
i would say more than anything the
little hitchiness throwing motion just
like we saw in those clips right there
there's there's no that separation all
the time with the upper and lower body
mic a lot of it is just [ __ ] the elbow
and then try to make it happen with that
and it leads to aaron throws all over
the field it's why even in the pro day
to me he can't just let it go like the
other guys can where he can just let me
throw my hundred mile per hour fastball
every time because he's not quite sure
where the ball is going to go so between
that elbow and then how big and
elongated his step can be to throw the
football at times those two things are
are concerning and i gotta think those
are the things that you know other
evaluators are seeing as well you know i
saw something recently
that i i kind of brushed past it but now
that you've got fields
making it all the way to the bottom of
the round bucky brooks
who uh does some scouting at nfl.com
yeah
he he
he believes
the ravens
should get fields and let lamar jackson
walk away be it make him the first guy
that you say hey you know what long-term
contract sorry we're fine with five
years we're we're we're just gonna we're
gonna reload at the quarterback position
that was an eyebrow razor for me it's
interesting
it's gonna be a hell of a thing to work
out a contract for lamar jackson number
one he doesn't have an agent what does
he want what does he want and you know
and uh how much of an investment do you
make and a guy that even though he
hasn't been injured yet that style of
play at some point could catch up to him
but i i i just i i've seen that and i
hadn't really paid attention to it but
i don't like that right
yeah you got 27 and 31. yeah you got the
ravens having two two cracks at it i'm
intrigued by what brooks is saying yeah
it's an interesting thought now here
this is what i don't like about you know
this motion there just
and there's a lot of pictures out on the
internet to
to show different positions justin
fields throws and i go
you're not going to see top flight
throwers be in this position a whole lot
but it's just so
elbow-oriented and that's where it gets
him in trouble a little bit the arm
becomes floppy but mike
you know help me understand what it does
i mean is it is it he holds it too long
and the defensive backs are going to get
a job one is a little bit of a jump and
then two it's just like too much of a
moving part to where it just hinges on
the elbow and you wouldn't see that
disconnect maybe with a brady or a
rogers or anything like that they don't
get it up to here and then just let the
arm flop it all comes together as one
and connected to their body field's arm
almost acts like an independent
contractor at times and that would be
like when we say hey he's throwing all
arm yeah there's too many throws where
he throws it all arm and that's what
makes him a really less than average
short ball thrower because there is no
technique involved he tries to figure oh
i'm going to throw it short and soft
well let me make my motion long and soft
and that's not really the proper thought
either it leads to a lot of errant
throws all over the place that way so
uh that that's the big issue with it
mike and
mike that thought about bucky bucky
brooks like it got me intrigued actually
you know if you're gonna get a running
quarterback and play that style of
football you almost view him as a
running back to a degree you know do you
start to think that way like hey we'll
get the next running quarterback in here
and continue to play this style of play
we don't think this quarterback can run
and do this all forever
uh it's an interesting thought
nonetheless i don't think they'll have
the guts to do it but might be something
like a few years from now somebody
finally does
and have them at the bottom of round one
too where you get a much lower contract
and if you take a top five guy one last
thing on the justin fields throwing
motion and i think i know the answer to
this but there may be some people who
are confused because
we praise patrick mahomes
for being all over the place right but
it's different though it's different he
makes it work he's accurate well he
doesn't let his arm get to this position
and then just let it be like this right
he's he's like this but when it comes to
throwing it all comes together with his
body right it all comes there together
where feels it's here and then it's [ __ ]
the elbow and then go go gadget arm
right and that that's where you know
mahomes has mastered
the perfect technique and now
that allows him to go wait i got it i'm
the man i've already i perfected the
driver down the middle of the fairway
now i'm gonna work on you know draws and
cutting the ball and doing those type of
stuff to where he can you know do
whatever he wants and that's what i mean
by the sidearm stuff and the awkward
deliveries and all that if that's a good
analogy
100 bucks says you slice it into the
woods all right uh
i was watching caddyshack the other day
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports